[Music]
cool drug or exclude or near Canal Gong
light it's critical diet in my hair
there are a kimochi no not gonna need a
nun there
[Music]
Tajima Jewish to monitor the Gujarati or
the moon or Sun diagrams so Rosangela
wollongong holidays choreography
they cannot deny me - Tori oh you the
Guru is improperly but the correlation
tracking can unlock a door to the garage
not an illusion and gray my garage must
under schedule even know each cat Atoka
you will know who is a Tova you will
know cause of Stoker so emo no no city
isolated till mover Emilio grandeur in
Kanazawa Thomas decoder on Oh Jane gonna
do tomorrow kitey kitey Oshima's see
kinda ni truck code skirt in over or
that you know if you go mean and then
now I wa
yeah what a u.s. colleges when kumoi do
you multitude on my day we came from
record giggles a map Takara Queen on
Iona presented in egt this is Alana so
now my gosh could see Mercedes so erotic
niyama is a much higher honor in a car
horrible Volvo you kill anything cos
theta has to bear Coco Rocha yes a
little
oh okay so if you are not quite the
image the way you are in this cat off
the water Amitabha Kona Hawaii roto
Hawaii tour of comity running Ning and
holding a data room there as oh we got
Ric
[Music]
the water Otto is their schools mio
Honda my rotisserie kimochi wa
multimodal it was regarding a tango not
only answer the moon canoe know who is
what I tell people enjoy mayhem
especially when it happens to other
people
there's definitely a factor of
schadenfreude watching something go
terribly wrong to someone else
[Music]
you're in a u-haul you're about to start
your first semester at Duke and driving
down the road you see this Sun and
another sign anybody no attention and
then this sign lights up and then
disaster strikes you're about to get
your 15 minutes of fame all thanks to
this man
hi I'm uragan hen these infamous nice
parts right you're good one could say
that yes
hey yeah no no see eleven foot eight guy
around here you're getting his wife
started eleven foot eight calm which is
what exactly
11:48 web site records all the truck
crashes that happen here at the 11:48
bridge it's really all it is eight years
ago I set up camera outside my office
here and started recording the traffic
that goes under the railroad trestle
behind me within a few weeks I recorded
a truck crashing into the railroad
bridge since installing the camera
Jurgen has uploaded a video of a hundred
and thirteen crashes at the bridge and
amassed over ten million views most
bridges in the state have a 15-foot
clearance
the 11 foot 8 bridge however is both a
hundred years ago hence lower height and
now thanks to you again these crashes
the dedicated following our fans are
really intensely interested in these
crashes and they love to buy souvenirs
little piece of crash art what's crasher
the crash art are bent mangled pieces of
aluminum that usually form the frame of
the truck and the impact crushes that
aluminum
and kind of twists it in interesting
shapes people will buy the crash art
they love it for some of them it's
almost like owning a piece of the Berlin
Wall
what isn't the town just raise the
trestle or lower the rope from the
perspective of the city and the state do
t the low clearance is clearly marked
and it's up to the driver to decide
their next move
structural change is that this
intersection would be extremely costly
well at least we have these awesome
videos right I get no satisfaction out
of seeing a new crash if we found an
actually solution to prevent this
tomorrow I'd be all over it I love it
[Music]
to anyone who says I'm too young or
girls can't do it I would say come on to
Monster Jam event watch me compete and
watch me win
[Music]
I'm Rosalie Raymer at the world's
youngest professional female lobster
cart driver when I first sat in the seat
of a monster truck I was 11 I started
competing at age 14 and I've been
competing ever since I could drive a
monster truck before I could drive a car
down the road I'm studying mechanical
engineering at Georgia Tech and I'm
working on making the monster truck of
my dreams I'm working on lowering the
center of gravity of the Moss truck so
that has better handling and more
capability as when we're out there on
the field competing first I got an idea
about how I want to improve a monster
truck then I put some ideas down on
paper and my sketch pad I get to put
that into the computer so I can work
with it on a higher level and I get to
3d print it having a technical mind is
definitely advantage on the field I know
exactly how my truck works and it allows
me to read how it's doing on the track I
can fix anything that's wrong with my
truck wildflower is the first truck I
got to help build putting that paint
those big flowers on my truck that
really shows Who I am and I'm proud of
that and I hope that that makes little
girls to Dula princesses and who do love
flowers more over minded to the world of
big trucks and machinery and
I'm proud of Who I am I am a woman
I Drive big trucks I've gotten several
nicknames one of the biggest ones that
stick out in my mind was one run
Anderson I would run one time but I'm
gonna tell you right now you better have
your camera's ready because it was gonna
be one big bad run I'm Dennis Anderson
and I'm the original grave digger
if you don't know what a monster-truck
is it's because you're a concrete
cruising city slicker the definition of
a monster-truck is it has to have a 6643
Terra tire meaning 66 inches tall 43
inches wide and normally they're around
10 to 12 foot tall and 12 foot wide and
they usually weigh about 10 to 12,000
pounds that's what a monster truck is my
goal in life as a kid growing up is I
wanted to be this big farmer it never
really was a goal in life for me to be a
pro Monster Jam truck driver
the whole legacy of gravedigger this
right here was the first stepping stone
my goal in life as I was building this
truck was to have a big nice shop with a
concrete floor because I built this
thing in a 10 chicken house
I call it my Empire and it's the
gravedigger Empire here now we're up to
nine grave diggers we've built 32 grave
digger trucks in the last 34 years this
is the dyno room my most favorite place
on the property 1,500 horsepower and
we're going to see a test pool right now
[Music]
yeah baby trust me I have paid my dues
all the way down the line
I have fractured my back I've broke my
shoulder I've broke my ribs I broke my
nose a couple of times I've broke my
arms when you talk about living a dream
that's this old guy right here I never
have grown up
I still love toys and that's why
gravedigger is what it is today I think
I've came up with the largest collection
of whole American cars in the world
you know all of them have the story but
they kindly take their place in the
forest you know and they're part of the
forest
they grew up partially in the forest
[Music]
my name is Walter Dean Lewis
I've run and operated in my own Holkar
City USA I was born and raised in a
junkyard and I like junkyards
[Music]
this land was clear when I started
putting them in there I wanted nature to
take its course and we just had to go
wild
these cars come from other junkyards and
just individual people and they all wind
up here no car city
[Music]
Ford Chevrolet Joe motors they land out
there in the forest rotting away
[Music]
we build things out of rushed out there
and it is a pitch line
[Music]
you
[Music]